Progressive centrist. What the you mean?
Wait, maybe this guy's aing idiot. Wait,
maybe this guy's just like a total Maybe
this guy's like dumb as hell. The only
thing Hutch proved here is that he reads
below a high school level and then just
moves on. Just moves on like he didn't
just totally loop and get like an idiot.
Nice one, Hutch.
>> Can you read that sentence again?
>> I can read it right now.
>> So, there's a longunning drama that I
thought was dead to be honest. I thought
it was dead over a political
organization, a streamer political group
called Chorus that was set up primarily
by this guy called Brian Tyler Cohen,
who's a big liberal content creator on
YouTube. And basically after the
election loss, he came out with this
pitch. And his pitch was basically
something exactly like this. He said
something to the effect of, "Do you ever
just feel like all the Republicans have
gone into a Monday morning meeting and
come out with the perfect talking points
and they just they're all pushing the
party line and they're all defending
Trump? Imagine if we could do that, but
for the Dems." That was basically what
he said almost verbatim. I'm lifting
that from JTO a little bit, but I also
remember him remember him saying it very
clearly. And Taylor Loren basically did
an article. Taylor Ren is a journalist.
Many of you may know quite hated. Quite
hated. She has had some issues in her
reporting here and there before, but the
broad factual claims of this article
were pretty much unimpeachable. And
basically what happened was she got her
hands on some contracts for this
organization chorus that they were
having streamers sign. and her along
with the wired editorial staff, legal
team, whatever, reviewed these contracts
and detailed sort of what was in them
and some of the interactions that people
had had with Chorus in the process of
signing them or not signing them in some
cases. And basically, these contracts
mandated that any bookings creators
wanted to do with political figures had
to go through this thing called the
Chorus newsroom. So, it was basically
all channelneled through Chorus, all
funneled through Chorus. All their
contacts and everything were found
through Chorus and they weren't allowed
to disclose their relationship with
Chorus, the fact they were getting paid
or their relationship or Chorus'
relationship with this dark money fund
for liberal projects, dem Democrat
projects called the 1630 fund. Dark
money for those who who don't know, it's
uh it's political typically election
related uh uh finance that you don't
know the source of. It isn't fully
declared. you don't know, you can't
track the source of and they typically
go through uh a few different types of
specific uh funding structures in order
to obscure that information is is
basically the the gist of it. Uh
obviously you can read way more into it.
You can go you look it up on your own
time. You don't really need to know all
the details to understand what's going
on there. Now this all happened a while
ago. This all happened like six plus
months ago. This is like old old drama.
And Destiny lost two debates, if you can
believe it, to Taylor Loren herself over
this. Uh, and he just started spuring
out and started acting like dark money
was any money that you don't know 100%
the source of, even if it's going
throughout limited companies for like
non-political related projects. That's
still dark money apparently, which like
a stupid definition that nobody uses uh
for dark money. uh he just wanted to
blow it up into a completely vacuous
term so that he could label this certain
type of funding that Taylor was getting.
She gets funding from it's a it's a
journalism grant that a bunch of
journalists get from this thing called
the Amidia Group. It's run by some
billionaire basically. He claims it's
private money. Obly you can't 100% know
that because it's it's a it goes through
a um a limited company or whatever. And
basically he says um yeah it's it's a
personal project. I'm doing it to fund
it because I believe in in the cause,
you know, funding the press. And that's
that's the idea. And so Destiny labels
that dark money too to try and make to
try and draw an equivalence with
campaign election spending, which
obviously political in nature, partisan,
political in nature, which is a
different thing, which is what dark
money is specifically referring to in
any definition of dark money you look
at. So that that all happened quite a
while ago, guys. Now, Taylor Loren's for
some time now has been booked to appear
on Pisco, Hutch, IRI, and the Soy Pills
podcast, Live and Learn. That's been
delayed a few times. And then she
finally appeared yesterday or the day
before, giving Hutch his opportunity to
confront Taylor Loren's. He had
disagreements with her article. He had
he had some disagreements with her
article and he wanted to defend, you
know, moderate Dems, Brian Tyler Cohen,
the idea of them using dark money. He
wanted to defend all of this. So, he
wanted to confront Taylor ends. If you
know anything about Hutch's previous
confrontations, he does get in his
feelings quite a bit, especially if he
feels like, especially if he gets a
sense that his friends, the peace guy
especially, aren't backing him up or are
sort of taking the wind out of his sales
or, you know, basically if anyone says,
even if they agree with his conclusion
and they're on the same team and
everything, if someone says, "H, I don't
think that's a good argument," he's
going to get really upset. And that
happened in the Taylor N's appearance.
Pisco, you could see, was sitting there
biting his tongue for extended periods
of time as they looped on certain
points, which we're going to go over in
a minute. And eventually he does start
saying stuff to Hutch. He does start
saying, "Hutch, listen, you got to just"
and Hutch starts getting very, you know,
in his feelings, very defensive, which
we're going to take a look at. And it's
spiraled, guys. It's just totally
spiraled. And he's now been on Pisco for
hours today, having the same thing
happen, hashing it out again and again.
And it's getting to the point I think
honestly Hisco is going to struggle if
he doesn't just start calling out what's
happening. And it's difficult because
he's friends with like a total [__] who
literally cannot hear anything negative
said about himself ever without
descending into just like a total
crybaby fit. But it is apparent that
Hutch is terrible at arguing, incredibly
biased, and he gets hyped up like
[__] crazy when Destiny and DGG give
him a little bit of an ego boost. If
they if they come down and side with
Hutch, he gets such an ego boost. And he
is consciously, deliberately
using it against Pisco in their
conversations. He is consciously
deliberately using basically trying to
set up so Pisco gets attacked by DG
apparent as [__] And Pisco stand sits
there treading on [__] eggshells
desperately trying to not say anything
that could even remotely be interpreted
as as snarking him or as siding with the
commies, siding with Taylor, not backing
him up. He's like desperately walking on
eggshells trying not to upset this guy
and he need he just needs to start
calling out what's happening when it's
happening because it's impossible. It's
impossible to watch, man. And you can
see he is getting so frustrated with it
while it's happening. So let's uh let's
take a look first at Lib and Learn. So
this is where the first big disagreement
starts and they loop on this
disagreement for for a long time. Okay,
let's take a look. Well, my sense of of
this particular reporting is that I
think you do have a slant and I think
you do I think your opinion is
>> my slant is is probably I mean as you
can read from all my wired reporting
it's against dark money and it's it's
it's it is a transparency.
>> Well no no that's not the slant that I'm
talking about. I think you have an
anti-establishment slant. I think I
think you've discussed you've
anti-establishment
>> hang real quick. you you've described
yourself as on the left or you I think
you even hinted that you were identified
with the label of leftist I think in
your conversations in certain Sure. you
read the article, it's like really clear
that you have villains in the story and
you have heroes in the story and you
have kind of a larger narrative that I
think I think goes beyond
>> but like 15 people were right but like
my name is on the top but as you know
with
>> so I will agree with Hutch in this that
there's villains in the story in the
sense that there is a party that is seen
as do as as engaging in wrongdoing.
That's true. Yeah, she's betraying uh
chorus the 1630 fund um etc as engaging
in wrongdoing. Brian Ted Cohen is
engaging in in wrongdoing. She's not
saying they're evil. She's not saying
they are villains, but the story kind of
has a villain. It it says, you know,
they are mandating that people don't
disclose their relationship. That's bad.
That's wrong. I don't Do you have a
problem with that, Hutch? Is that Is
that a problem?
>> An investigation like this, especially
one that went to the top that like 15
people worked on this story. So,
>> oh, well, I understand that, but like
for example, so you you assigned the
label uh centrist to Olivia Giulianiana,
>> which is how she selfidentified.
>> No, she selfidentifies as a progressive,
right?
>> No, I from what I found from my original
reporting back from the New York Times,
back when I had interviewed her years
ago, she was identifying as a centrist
Democrat
>> back in Texas. That was her whole thing
as
>> in 20 in 2024,
>> maybe. It was whenever I spoke to her
her, which was a lot quite a while ago.
But to but just to be clear, she never
took issue with that. She never reached
out for a correction on that at all. We
would have been happy to like if she
>> Well, I mean, nonetheless, that that
that is an opinion, right? Subject. It's
a very subjective way of how she Well,
first of all, I think we can correctly
identify people's political sort of
affiliations. For instance, if she's I
thought, correct me if I'm wrong on
Olivia Giulianiana, and Olivia
Giulianiana works for Chorus. Um, but
she
>> This is the big disagreement for a huge
part of the panel. Is this Olivia
Juliana woman a centrist? Okay. I don't
want to watch the whole thing here
because it is boring as [__] But
basically, Taylor N says, "I spoke to
her a few years ago. She told me she
told me she was a centrist. That's what
I'm going on to call her a centrist."
Hutch says, "No, that's not good enough.
That's not good enough." That seems like
a fine reason to me. That seems like a f
That seems like a fine reason to me.
>> Her whole thing was that she was a
Democrat in Texas, right, who had done a
lot of work with like reproductive
justice.
>> Yeah. Right. So she focuses on abortion,
LGBTQ plus, climate, voting rights. When
I look at these sort of policy uh
priorities that does not strike me as a
when I think of a centrist, I think of
Joe Mansion. I think I think of like
Jared from Nebraska, right? The centrist
label is very vague and broad. It's it's
incredibly vague and broad. Someone can
be a centrist and believe in abortion,
you know, climate change, gay marriage.
Someone can be a centrist and believe in
all those things very easily. very
easily. One example is a lot of people
may consider themselves uh economically
uh uh conservative but sort of like
socially liberal. Um in that case
someone would be progressive cuz
progressive most of the time, not always
but most of the time relates to social
issues but they're more conservative
fiscally. So they see it the way they
see it is they're sort of in the middle.
You know they have agreements on both
sides. So they'll label a they label
themselves a centrist. So you'd have a
progressive centrist. It's just not it's
not that strict of a term that it's
worth arguing over, you know, the matter
of fact here as to whether it can apply.
>> Olivia wants to reach out and and we
honestly the the thing that you're
bringing up mostly comes up. The thing
is Q that he thinks so what Hutch is
trying to prove is Hutch is trying to
prove that Taylor was attempting to use
the article as essentially propaganda as
pro-lefty anti-modderate propaganda
because every everything's about Hassan
everything and he needs to maintain his
his space in the politics streamer
ecosystem. Okay. So he's trying to
explain, he's trying to prove that
Taylor is doing this as propaganda,
pro-lefty against moderate Dems. And so
he's saying, "Well, you use centrist
even though it doesn't fit because that
serves your purposes of villainizing the
centrists. That serves your purpose.
She's actually a progressive." Um, now
even if he did prove that centrist
didn't fit, which is going to be hard
because it's a very vague term that can
be used differently in different contra
contexts, it it would barely go like one
or two% of the way towards proving its
point. It's like not very significant at
all. So, does it say something? Yeah, it
says something if if she was misusing
that, but it barely it really barely
contributes. uh it's like a worthless
point to get hung up on for like 40
minutes of the podcast
>> up on the right because for instance
when I've covered Nick Fuentes he will
say well I'm not a white nationalist or
Chuck Johnson who I cover all the time
or not so much anymore actually he's
less relevant but he would constantly
say well I'm not a Holocaust denier
right and so I think at some point you
do have to take a look at certain
people's you know beliefs and what
they've expressed and try
>> how would you how would you define
centrist how would you define centrist
>> a Democrat a Democrat that's probably
middle of the road like a middle of the
road Democrat like a Democrat that could
operate in a in a red state probably and
a blue state maybe equally like you know
somebody that's
>> very broad though that's a very very
broad
>> it's kind of a like the centrism itself
like as I think about and sit here um
there's a kind of identified more
Schumer oriented Democrat more moderate
Democrat especially with um a centrist
label and it is kind of vague right it
is it's a kind of vague term like yeah I
think I wouldn't say that the the chorus
I mean chorus has made content with
Schumer like I don't I I guess it's I
would say it's a very vague term it's
probably the most broad term because I
don't think we want to get it again like
>> the important thing here Taylor is to
Hutch's point based on and I I found
this when I read your article too you
you use centrist as like a porative
right
>> no for this one we say that like when
>> in general you do you you don't like the
Democrats and you especially don't like
centrist Democrats
on certain issues. I think it depends on
the type of
>> Do you use centrist as a
>> porative? You use centrist as a
pjorative, right? Like you you view
these people as like these feckless do
nothings and like I'm not
>> I think you're completely putting words
in my mouth that I have not said. I
think I don't like Chuck Schumer and a
lot of like there's a lot of what he
says, but there's a lot of people that
are quote unquote centrist that I
absolutely respect and work with and
that worked on this article. Like
there's people that like just to be
clear, this article went through so many
editors that have such a range of
political beliefs. And I hear you that
maybe you disagree that that Olivia
Giulianiana is classified as as we
described her a centrist Jenzi
influencer who spoke at the 2024 DNC
issue with that. And I
>> that that's not really that that's not
really that's beside the point. I mean
whether or not she disputed it. I think
that if most people Well, hang on. Just
let me real quick. I I am trying to be
I'm not trying to cut you off very much.
So, just let me let me see what I think
I think if like a reasonable person went
to Olivia Giulianiana's feed and they
saw her policy uh priorities, I think
that they would like colloial
colloquially understand her to be just
sort of sort of like a standard Gen Z
progressive Democrat who's focused on
progressive.
>> Progressive is also the the reason
progressive has come up.
>> So, yeah, progressive can mean different
things in different contexts as well.
There are progressives like people might
say you people use it as like a
qualifier of a group of dems basically.
It's like AOC is like one of the
progressives you know as opposed to the
moderate centrists or um you even
compared to a leftist or something like
that. Then there's progressive as like a
disposition. That's what you might mean
when you say someone's a progressive
centrist. They might believe in abortion
and gay marriage and climate change, but
on most things are sort like in the
center or maybe slightly lean right on
on like a lot of other issues. So
they're a centrist and progressive
touch. It's not it does not necessarily
preclude you from being one or the
other. They're not mutually exclusive
terms because they can mean different
things in different contexts and one can
be sort of like a qualifier of the other
>> up so much. And somebody was trying to
get me to write a story about this
recently which I was like this is not
really my beat. um is because so many
people have tried to replace the word
centrist.
>> Dude, dude, it's so funny as well. It's
so funny. Bunch of people who are like I
I know I'm I'm being insane. I'm being
schizophrenic. Kathy's rubbed off on me.
I'm obsessed. I'm crazy. People will be
like, "No, you don't understand. When
said y'all was a great guy, she meant he
was a moderating voice in the cabinet.
No, I understand. He still call
Palestinians human animals, but dur in
the context of the cabinet of the Gaza
war, he would say, you know, they'll
give you this whole [__] they'll give
you this whole [__] thing. It's like
progressive centrist. What the [__] do
you mean? [__] retards, man. It's so
crazy.
>> Progressive. And this has been like a
thing that influencers were actually
given to this is totally separate from
my story and this is like a something
else. Maybe I'll write about it. I don't
know. Probably not. But um there is an
effort as the word as certain words
become stigmatized or have negative you
know maybe you're saying this has like a
negative view with with some people
they're trying to use other words. So
you see them use the word progressive
instead of centrist or the word whatever
whatever.
>> No no I'm not talking about self-
assigned labels. I mean I think most
people would look at her policy
proposals and think okay that's just
>> what you think about Biden Hush. I mean,
uh, let's be honest, right? Like, so if
if Biden were described as a centrist
Democrat, dude, look at him already. All
right, Pisco has just chimed in a couple
of times. They've been stuck on this
point for a good few minutes now. And
Pisco starts chiming in just a little
bit.
>> Was a Biden deadender. So, she
absolutely Biden Democrat.
>> That does not.
>> Would you describe Biden? Hang on.
Bernie were Biden.
>> Exactly. Yes. AOC and Bernie Sanders.
>> I would describe them as Dem. I guess
they're notism. They're progressives,
right? They're progressives, right? That
doesn't make them as centrist.
>> I would call them democratic socialists,
right?
>> Well, listen. If you if you had to
choose between progressive and centrist
to describe AOC and Bernie, what would
you choose?
>> I don't I It totally depends on the
context of the article.
>> Bernie has been No, because look at what
Bernie has been doing with his AI
policy. Like I just I think
>> Nobody would call him his centrist.
Nobody Nobody would call him but I
wouldn't call him progressive either on
certain things. I I just I just I I
don't understand what these words mean
anymore. I mean like
>> Yeah. Okay. Bernie is a leftist, but
he's not particularly progressive. He is
centrist on some issues. For instance,
he's always cited for like the tariffs
and immigration [__] There are plenty
of situations where you could totally
describe Bernie as either not being
progressive or being centrist. To label
him as a centrist, full stop. No, that
would obvious that would probably be
stupid. That would probably be like, you
know, incoherent. Wouldn't communicate
what you mean to wouldn't be an accurate
summation of his views, but certainly in
some context you can describe him as
being a centrist on that issue.
>> More broadly, more broadly, you said you
said that there were 90. Did you see a
list of 90 people? Is that is that how
many people you saw?
>> So, just to be clear, I I understand
that you take issue with the way that
editors categorize these people, but
>> that's an opinion, though. You're
inserting.
>> It's not an opinion. Well, this is Chuck
Johnson saying that us calling him a
Holocaust denier is an opinion or us
saying that Tucker Carlson is a
right-winger is an opinion. All we can
do is try to best reflect the ideology
that often we use self self-escribed
ideologies. But all we can do
>> I think she self-describes as a
progressive at this point. So that's
that's where I'm a little bit
>> at this point maybe. But who I would say
I would say again if you ask actual
people that are further to the left than
her they will say not. So,
>> well, that's the issue. That's the
issue. More leftist will call Bernie
Sanders a centrist, but it's not
accurate.
>> No, but that but but that's the issue
because I think you're framing your
article from the position of like the
the the left.
>> But I didn't even write that line. But I
didn't even write that line. So, like I
just
>> Well, your name's on your name's on the
course. But I want you to understand how
journalism works, right? The way that
journalism works, it's not just that
that Wired is my personal blog and I can
go and write whatever I want, right? and
I can just go and publish on Wired and
nobody's going to look at it, right? No.
Especially with an investigation like
this, the way it happens is I find
information, right? I get people trying
to whistleblow in this case about a
program that they're in. And I go to an
editor and I say, "Hey, I have all of
this source material, all of this
people, would you be interested in a
story?" Yes. Okay. I work with that
editor to draft the story. It then goes
through rounds, in this case, rounds and
rounds and rounds and rounds of review
from many different editors that not
only transform the story, rewrite parts
of the story, add things, take things
away, but also then it goes through
legal review, then it goes through copy
edits and stuff like it goes. So, but I
just want you to understand because I
think yes, my name is at the top of the
story because this is my reporting. This
is my reporting that I brought forward
fundamentally. But if you're going to
take issue with like random sort of
characterizations and again I understand
>> I don't think it's random. I think it
was deliberate. I think it was
deliberate.
>> Why don't you get to there? I mean like
I mean why don't you go there and just
ask Taylor
>> the copy editor.
>> I'm trying to have a conversation with
her. I don't know why you're jumping in
here.
>> No. Because it's kind of a stupid
critique to be like hey
he's kind of in the eye
>> my report. So yeah, here Pisco starts
getting frustrated with how repetitive
the conversation has become very clearly
and starts stepping in a little bit more
and basically tells Hutch this is
[__] [__] Come on, just just
move the [__] on. Centrist can mean many
different things in many different
contexts. It's a vague term. arguing
over the minutia of whether this more
moderate Dem is is a centrist or a
moderate Dem or or a progressive or what
is [__] and a waste of your time.
You don't get much close to proving your
point and you should move on something
stronger.
>> This is my reporting that I brought
forward fundamentally. But if you're
going to take issue with like random
sort of
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The failure of
Pisco is that he stops at Hutch has a
stupid point and not that Hutch is
stupid. Exactly. How many stupid points
with what regularity with what percent
what percentage of points that come out
of someone's mouth have to be totally
[__] [__] and worthless before
you just go wait maybe this guy's a
[__] idiot. Like maybe this guy's
just like a total [__] maybe this
guy's like dumb as hell
>> characterizations. And again, I
understand
>> I don't think it's random. I think it
was deliberate. I think it was
deliberate.
>> Why don't you get to there? I mean like
I mean why don't you go there and just
ask Taylor
>> the copy editor.
>> I'm trying to have a conversation with
her. I don't know why you're jumping in
here.
>> No, no, no. Because
>> so he's so mad. He cannot believe he's
got Soy pill on his side. IRI staying
out of it. It's basically it's basically
if you take it aside, which it which it
isn't. Pisco agrees with Hutch and Soy
Pill's conclusion. He just thinks this
is a stupid argument. If you take it
aside, it's a 2v2. And he's [__]
crying about Pisco jumping in when Soy
Pills jumped in against Taylor. It's
kind of a stupid critique to be like,
hey, um, you know, centrist is kind of
in the eye of the beholder. Like, yeah.
So, Joe Biden would describe himself as
a centrist Democrat. Correct? Yes or no?
>> No.
>> Wait, wait. Can you answer that first?
Can you answer that? So, the question
the question you should ask, The
question you should ask is Let me
finish.
>> The question that you should ask is,
Taylor, do do you were you attempting to
imply something nefarious when you used
Centress there? Were you trying to imply
that they were aligned with the DNC?
>> Well, ask a question about her
intention.
>> Listen, I Taylor Respectfully, I think
you were I think you were doing that. I
think you did.
>> I didn't even write I wrote the list of
influencers names. I didn't even
originally
>> Well, here we have we have we have
another spot here where you say that uh
>> before you wait before you do the next
thing. I I cuz
>> I can't you did say that soy bill jumps
in as well. So, we're going to we're
going to move on from that point. We are
going to move on from that point. What's
your opinion of the article? Um
basically the article is almost all
factually true. I think well no it is
all factually true as far as I can tell.
The biggest criticism is Pisco's
criticism which is that the by line says
and we're about to hear some of this in
a minute. The by line basically says
content creators were paid to push the
party line which implies a direct
exchange of money to talk. That didn't
quite happen. It was a PV type setup
where they're receiving a monthly
funding, a monthly grant, and they show
up to weekly meetings to have talking
point sessions and receive daily news
briefings to tell them what the Democrat
stories are for that day. Um, there's
not a direct we pay you this and you say
that.
>> Hutch vaping while he's six months
pregnant is disgusting.
>> Thank you for the $5 from the Southside.
Thank you. Appreciate it. So yeah,
that's what I think of the article. Now,
the point they're going to argue over
here is that Taylor described it, Taylor
said that of the influencers they
identified being part of the program,
and you can't identify them all because
they were prevented from disclosing it
by contract. Um, and it wasn't
published, they didn't publish a roster
or anything. The of the creators they
identified being part of the program,
they were primarily pro DNC,
pro-establishment, pro-Israel. That's
what Taylor claims. I believe in a
tweet, not in the article. I believe in
in a tweet, maybe it's in the Aqua, I'm
not sure. I think it gets hashed out
here. Either way, though, the claim is
of the ones they identified, and they
can't identify them all, they are
primarily pro-Israel, prom, pro DNC. And
Taylor splits pro-Israel into in sort of
two camps, which is outright pro-Israel
or silent because she's saying that it's
basically seen by the democratic
establishment as an inconvenience to
have to address Gazi. We'd rather just
not take a stance and not taking a
stance is defaulting to Israel because,
you know, the change is moving away from
Israel. The current status quo is
Israel. So opposing the status quo is,
you know, necessary. Otherwise, you're
just signing on status quo. That's bas
basically the argument. She doesn't say
all of that, but that is basically the
argument. She does say she splits it
into those two camps though of
pro-Israel asylum. Um, so yeah, let's
let's listen to a bit of that. Let's
listen argue over whether you can
identify them as primarily pro DNC, pro
Israel.
>> If they are not if I was wrong, if if
this article is wrong and it's factually
wrong, then I highly encourage them to
ask for a correction. But no one has
asked.
>> Can we do it step by step?
They are not centrist. No one. Let's
just do it step by step. Hutch, is it
your content?
>> So, you can see we we've moved like 20
minutes on. Still going. Still going.
This point
>> that it's inaccurate to call Olivia
Juliana a centrist.
>> I do believe that. Yes. And I think that
she's virtue of what intentionally Well,
I don't know why you're separate.
It's a separate No, wait. No, hang on.
So, separate that intent. So, you can
make a you can make a critique of an
article based on its accuracy or based
on whether there's some ma bad motive in
that term. to a large.
>> Is it your contention? I know, but I'm
Let's just Let's just do it step by
step. Let's do it step by step. Is it
inaccurate? And so, and if it's
inaccurate, why is it inaccurate?
>> It's inaccurate because her policy
priorities do not line up with what any
reasonable person would assert to be a
centrist when you look at she's and the
that's fine. I mean, you can say you can
just make this argument about anything.
>> But what does it mean to be pro DNC or
pro- Israel? What does that mean? pro
well so pro DNC means pro-democrat like
pro sort of the democrat establishment
what I would say which is very much
chorus's goal and pro- Israel means that
the majority of people that that that we
found that were public which is why I
think it's so crucial for them to
actually release these names publicly
because I think if this is not the
majority view held among their creators
they should release these names publicly
to make it clear what is the ideological
makeup of their chorus class um but the
a lot of the people that we found um
were also pro-Israel meaning they
wereing support for Israel against and
and and
>> how many creators out of like all the
creators that you saw would you say were
posting pro-Israel posts? Can you name
names there?
>> Well, that's the point, right? Is that
they haven't p published the roster.
They haven't published the roster, but a
decent amount of ones that we that we
checked. Um,
>> did anybody in the in the people that
you mentioned in the article, so like
Olivia Pacman, Brian Teller Cohen, did
any of them post pro-Israel content?
You'll have to go check their specific
feeds, but Brian Tyler Cohen
>> claimed that they were primarily pro
Israel, right?
>> Yeah. Well, some people that are
pro-Israel just don't speak about the
genocide in Gaza at all, for instance.
And that's
>> So, yeah, I think this comes up, but
basically Yeah. Yeah. So, my
understanding is that a former Pac-Man
producer basically said, "Yeah, God
stuff's too divisive. We're not
covering." Basically said that Pac-Man
said, "Yeah, God stuff's divisive, so
we're never covering it. We're never
covering it." I'm pretty sure Pacman has
been pro Israel in the past, but they
basically decided, yeah, we're not
covering it. So, obviously Taylor is
identifying David Pacman as pro-Israel.
I think I don't think that's an
unreasonable conclusion to come to. I
really don't.
>> Same thing as being pro- Israel.
>> Yes. Because a way Yes. Because a way
that pro-Israel um narratives have been
shaped by the media is by not mentioning
the genocide. So refusing, intentionally
refusing to cover the genocide,
especially as it was this politically
relevant topic.
>> Is that what you were alleging?
>> No, no, that's Well, I'm just saying
like if you look at the pro-Israel kind
of creator landscape, there's a range of
pro-Israel people. There's people that
are straight up making content with the
IDF. They're super overt about it. And
then there are people that are a little
bit more behind the scenes, people that
are a little bit quieter about it.
still by the way that you kind of you're
suggesting that if somebody chooses not
to discuss the genocide in Gaza and like
that makes them pro-Israel. I find that
No, that's not what I said. That's not
what I said. What I said is that people
No, what I said is that some people who
are pro-Israel, they're the way that
they sort of the the way that their
content manifests is that they are not
as overt. So what they'll do is they'll
try to tamp down discussion. They'll be
sometimes deleting comments, a lot of
times just intentionally ignoring the
issue or when they were asked to
interview a politician, especially this
was a big issue in the leadup to the
2024 election. You had people saying
like sort of minimizing the issue,
attempting to minimize it, attempting
not to get people on the left to talk
about it.
>> Does that apply to any creator that was
>> I think only two out of the 90 creators
had a firmly pro Palestine position. I
don't think we can know that. I don't
think we can know that it that may it
may be the case that you've only
identified two that have prop Palestine
stances, but we don't actually know who
all 90 are. So, you can't you can't make
that firm of a claim. um which is what
Taylor's saying is she's saying that's
her big criticism of it is they should
tell everyone who's on the thing and
then maybe people wouldn't have this you
know perspective unless of course it's a
justified perspective in which case
they'd be very incentivized to not
release uh uh the full list of of who's
there
>> mentioned in your article
>> um well you'll have to you'll have to go
through and do an audit of all of their
content but it's certainly certainly
>> it's not your job though you made the
claim you that the group was primarily
pro Israel. Isn't it your job to go
through their
>> from the group that from the group from
the amount from the group that that we
saw from the amount of creators that we
saw that was a common theme? But that's
that wasn't a necessarily a um
>> you didn't say a common theme. You said
they were primarily pro Israel.
>> Yeah. From the group of creators that we
saw that we were evaluating.
>> So I'll ask again. Was anybody that you
mentioned in your article someone that
you would say was pro- Israel?
>> Well, you'll have to go look at the
article and figure that out for yourself
based on the creators. I don't
understand.
>> But we're not going to There's a lot of
creators that we spoke to for this
article that we know are in chorus that
weren't mentioned in the article.
>> I'm just asking you if anyone in your
article you consider to be pro- Israel.
>> Well, I don't know. You'll have to I I
really don't I don't remember which
creators that we named and didn't name
off the top of our head, but I think you
can just go and look at them and frankly
ask the creators themselves. That's a
great thing.
>> I don't know why you would say that that
90 influencers were primarily
pro-Israel, but you can't name them.
>> No, she didn't say. So this keeps
happening. So this what I mean Hutch can
this podcast the only thing Hutch proved
here is that he reads below a high
school level. Okay, this is the the only
argument the only conclusion Hutch has
proved with his arguments here is that
he reads at a sub high school level
because here he is repeatedly reading
the claim of the ones we could identify
they were primarily pro- Israel pro DNC
and what he's interpreting from that is
of the 90 they were primarily pro-Israel
pro DNC but that's not the claim being
made there is a large group there's 90
creators is Taylor has identified a
limited number of them and of that
limited number they are primarily it's
an even smaller group pro Israel pro DNC
that's what she's saying she's not
making the claim that of those 90 it's
primarily okay that's not what she said
she can't she doesn't have the evidence
to make that claim
>> no we said 90 we said the creators in
that we were able to to sus out as being
part of the program so one thing that we
asked
>> one thing that we asked is for them to
publish a roster so that people could
take a a broader look maybe this This is
just a section, right? Maybe this is
just a small section that
>> could be an unrepresentative section.
>> Exactly. Exactly. It could be a totally
unrepresentative section. They could
have
>> What was the methodology to decipher
whether they're pro-Israel? Was it to
>> mostly whether like their own statements
or whether they had shown up in other
influencer like pro- sort of Israel
influencer efforts broadly. I mean,
there are people also that I've talked
to in this program that identify as
Zionists privately and don't want to
identify as a Zionist publicly. So, I
don't not trying to put specific
creators on blast. I actually don't
think that being pro or anti-Israel was
ever something that was necessarily um
you know something that that would get
you in or out of
>> yo thank you for the raid present Sunday
welcome in welcome in Sunday raiders
>> chorus at all but it clearly is a
>> that's useful to clear up. So so as you
sit here after I said that after the
story went up too. Yeah,
>> but as you go ahead,
>> but in your conversation on current
affair, you did absolutely buy into the
manufacturing logic that those hosts
were presenting, which they were saying
that they were heavily, heavily, heavily
suggesting that the creators that were
invited into course were chosen because
they were not speaking up about Gaza.
>> So, you're talking about a guy that used
to work for Brian Tyler Cohen who was
was working, but you worked for David
Pacman.
>> Yeah. So, this what I was referencing.
So, one of David Pacman's producers
basically claims this. There's a guy who
worked for David Pacman says, "Yeah,
David Pacman doesn't cover that [__]
He's like kind of pro Israel and doesn't
want to step into it. What's the
problem? What's wrong?" Tailor doesn't
say he's lying. Doesn't jump to David
Pacman's defense. Believes that to be a
plausible explanation given David
Pacman's previous stances and current
behavior. Oh, God forbid. God forbid.
What a what a insane conclusion to come
to.
>> I'm not going to disagree with whatever
he wants to say was his experience
working for David Pacman, one of the
leaders of Chorus. This is his former
>> producing on your he was commenting on
your reporting. They were he was going
>> No, no, he was going beyond his
experience and he was he was he was
suggesting that Chorus was choosing
creators because they were not speaking
up about Israel.
>> He said that he was told when he worked
for David Pacman that he was not that
they were not supposed to be overt about
the Israel stuff. You can go back and
listen to that and and take issue with
that. But he worked for he worked for
David Pacman. I'm not going to argue
with with him working for David Pacman.
>> He was speaking about your reporting.
They were talking in the context of his
job. He worked for David Pacman. He was
David Pacman's producer. So he would
know better than anyone whether David
Pacman, you know, what his boundaries
were around issues related to Israel and
what sort of content they wanted to put
up. He would know. He was literally
David Pacman's producer. So he knows a
lot better than I do. He has a lot more
visibility into David Pacman's content
than I do.
>> I think you're being evasive again
because I'm not talking about his
experience. I'm talking about his
characterization of your reporting.
>> Well, his characterization is shaped by
his experience, which he has a lot more
than I do.
>> You No, but you bolstered that that
suggestion of manufacturing consent
about this issue and got it.
>> I'm going to I'm going to again defer
you to him. He actually worked for
David. So,
>> you agreed with the framing, Taylor. You
agreed with the framing when they were
having that conversation. I again I
don't I he worked for David Pacman. So
if he says that this these were the
lines that David Pacman drove when he
worked for him and that David Pacman
told him this and he had visibility not
into just David Pacman but all these
sort of people that David Pacman worked
with I am going to listen to him because
again he's a primary source.
>> Okay. Another another part of your
reporting referred to
>> and just moves on just moves on like he
didn't just totally loop and get raped
like an idiot. Nice one. older article
that you wrote I think a few months
before this.
>> By the way, apparently Taylor does have
some like horrendous interviews where
she is like obviously biased and
agreeing with a bunch of stupid [__]
Apparently with Glenn Greenwald, she
basically just agreed with everything he
said. Um, so it's not like there aren't
examples you could bring up, but he's
just like banging on about this stupid
Pacman thing. first one and you had
described a 2024 situation where the
Biden administration was your quote was
snubbing creators who had lightly
criticized Biden. Is do you remember
saying that?
>> I think you're talking about my
Washington Post article when I wrote
about um the Biden administration
effectively blacklisting content
creators,
>> right? Yeah. And and and in your in your
Wired article about chorus, you
described that as uh the the the Biden
you said in 2024, President Joe Biden's
White House snubbed several prominent
content creators after they lightly
criticized the administration over its
policies on climate change, CO Gaza, and
the Tik Tok ban.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> Yeah. This gets into a bunch of stupid
[__] This is the moment, okay, that
really shows how illiterate Hutch is.
Now, Pisco gets a few moments to voice
his legitimate critique that, you know,
it blows Hutches out of the water about
the by line, making a clear statement of
sort of quid proquo, an exchange of
money for a statement when that isn't
exactly that wasn't the setup. That
wasn't the setup. So, Pis gets a brief
moment to raise that before it gets
derailed by Hutch's total inability to
read a sentence with more than one
clause. And we're going to break that
down, guys. We're going to re break that
down. So, I'm excited to get there.
>> That's a separate thing. They're
smearing the entire operation as being
about like covering for genocide. This
includes people like Brian Tyler Cohen
and David Pacman and Olivia Giulianiana.
Like they were, you know, Hassan himself
has made this claim like not even
remotely,
>> but you mentioned him. You mentioned him
in this article. You mentioned him in
the old article. You mentioned him tweet
the [__] Joe Rogan of the left or
whatever. No, but you're presenting the
virtuous alternative to the corrupt
democratic shills. That that's what
you're doing in this whole
>> I don't think Hassan is taking dark
money,
>> but you you're not are you rejecting
that that that's what you're doing? Like
that is what you're doing, right? Like
you're saying you have these like
radical leftist they're pure and they're
not corrupt and then you have the
corrupt pro DNC pro-Israel shills,
right?
>> Search my please search my Twitter feed
and see what I've said about the
leftist. I I feel like I'm losing my
mind.
>> I did search Taylor and I you have been
[__] on them quite a bit. So, soy
pill even. So, Goyill himself comes in
here. Thank you, Commodore Champ. Thank
you.
>> Huge appreciate for the $5 there. Thank
you so much. Um, so Goyill himself comes
in here to take the wind out of Hutch
sales. Taylor has said, "Look on my
Twitter. See what I've been saying about
leftists. I critique everyone." And also
like, "Yeah, yeah, right. Yeah, right."
So goes and looks. Goill goes and looks.
And what does he see when he gets there?
Oh, she critiques everyone. Oh, she
does. That is what happens. Oh, that's a
shame, isn't it? That's a shame, isn't
it, Hutch? So, I I will I will give
Hutch something here. Okay, I'll give
Hutch a little bit. The article does,
like I said earlier, frame a wrongdoing
as a party engaging in wrongdoing. But
is it a problem that she identifies that
there are influencers like Asan who
don't take dark money? Is that a pro? Is
it a problem that she identifies that?
Says, you know, not all influencers feel
the need to do this. Is that a pro? What
is the problem with that, Hutch? That
she's identified wrongdoing. You're
saying that's bad. Not all of them do
this. What is your problem with that?
>> I constantly criticize people all over
the political ideology. I very
intentionally don't identify with one
political faction over the other or
whatever. And again, I know that that
pisses everybody off in that political
faction. But what I'm saying is that if
you think that this is some bad faith
like article that's meant to like
valorize the left and like criticize
that, that's just not what the article
says. And I understand that my cont say
that they're not allowed to disclose
their relationship with chorus. How do
you explain that?
>> No, it's not though. That's not. We know
that's not true.
>> Wait, sorry. They aren't allowed to
>> Why is it untrue? Wait, why do you think
it's described in the Steel Man
that
let's go through this guys? Cuz this
this is where it really picks up. Okay,
so here is the sentence in question,
guys. So, do we see this here? According
to copies of the contract viewed by
Wired, the creator signed, the
influencers are not allowed to disclose
their relationship with Chorus or the
1630 fund or functionally that they're
being paid at all. Okay. So, so we see
this now. What does this mean, guys? It
means that Wired
a contract and that contract has a
clause has terms that say you are not
allowed to disclose your relationship
with Chorus or the 1630 fund. The
function of this is to stop them saying
that they're being paid at all. That's
that's what it's claiming. Okay, that's
the claim here. Hopefully, we all read
that fine.
>> I understand the left and like criticize
that. That's just not what the article
says. And I understand that my cont say
that they're not allowed to disclose
their relationship with Chorus. How do
you explain that?
>> No, it's not though. It's not. We know
that's not true.
>> Wait, sorry.
>> So, how do as such seen a copy of the
contract? Has he seen all 90 contracts?
He knows that the contracts don't have
this term in them. Is that what he's
saying? Because he's saying this claim
is untrue, right? He's saying this claim
is untrue. According to copies of the
contract viewed by Wire, the creators
signed, the influencers are not allowed
to disclose their relationship with
Chorus or the 1630 fund or functionally
they're being paid at all. So
something's got What's wrong here? Is it
that there's a clause dictating whether
they can disclose that they're being
paid by Chorus and the 1630 fund? You're
saying that's not true. You're saying
it's not true that wide viewed it. What
What are we saying is untrue here, Arch?
>> They aren't allowed to Why is it untrue?
Wait, why do you think it's describing
the steel
that I understand? Listen, I I have my
issue. I want to bring up my issues with
the with
>> Why do you think I'm saying that?
>> Wait, wait, hang on. I will definitely
address that. I will I will definitely I
will definitely address that says I will
I will definitely address that. Hutch
Hutch I will definitely So this still
mammy [__] is the most [__] baby
behavior in the [__] world, bro. Is
like legit the most just manchild [__]
Stand up and just explain your ideas
like a normal [__] person, like an
adult. It's crazy. You've had soy pill
on your side for most of the time. You
can handle answering a question when
Pisco asks you a question.
>> I I want to be I will I understand.
Listen, I I have my issue. I want to
bring up my issues with the with
>> Why do you think I'm saying that?
>> Wait, hang on. I will definitely address
that. I will I will definitely
report to I will definitely address
that. Hutch Hutch, I will definitely
address. So, I I want to be clear. I
have my own problems with with the
article. Well, it has to do actually
with contractual contractual language in
the title, but I mean at this point it's
been done to death.
>> I didn't write the title. I didn't write
the title. Don't
>> come the the contractual the the artic
are you asking me or asking Taylor?
>> Asking Taylor. Is is the subheading
wrong then?
>> But okay, but you can ask her.
>> That's so important. That's so
important. That's the subheading.
>> That's actually wrong.
>> Well, you just said you don't you didn't
write it. So, I mean,
>> journalists don't write their titles.
>> But you have influence on the by line on
the subheading, right? You can't
request. Did you request that
subheading? Wait, hang on.
>> No, it's correct. Why would I do that?
>> Hang on. Journalists can't request that
a subheading is changed.
>> So, basically, Taylor's argument here is
if it's not factually correct, she's not
going to argue against it because
ultimately it's up to the editors to
maximize the views on the website if
they want to write a salacious title. As
long as it's not factually inaccurate in
her view, then she's not going to
correct that. So, so that's what
Taylor's saying to them right now.
>> I would I would never do that unless it
was factually wrong. It's not factually
wrong.
>> This is absolutely factually wrong,
though. I mean, like in in your
subheading, you say that online
influencers were paid up to
>> We're getting on to this briefly.
>> $1,000 a month to push the party line.
>> Yeah.
>> Sorry. The the the decks in the the the
marketing decks push that describe
>> the marketing decks. We're talking about
a realistic like claim. You know, you're
saying that they were getting paid 8,000
to push the party line and there's no
deliverables. whole point of the program
was to fix the Democratic party's
messaging problem. That's the whole
point of the program.
>> But but you're saying paid X to do Y.
That's a consideration for some sort of
thing that in the other end of it. And
and I did have a question about it, but
I wanted to address what was just said
um about the characterization regarding
the disclosure. The article um states
that the contract, the language of the
contract forbids disclosure, and I don't
have any reason to believe that's
untrue. Um, yeah, there were there were
at what particular quote are you are you
pointing to here? Do you have the quote
in front of you?
>> I don't have it in front of me, but I
know it's characterizing the
>> the contract viewed by wire that
creators signed. The influencers are not
allowed to disclose their relationship
with chorus or the 1630 funds, but
that's not true.
>> Are you the accuracy of that? Why why is
it why do you think it's untrue?
>> Yeah. So, Hajj, lay it out for us. What
part of that is false? What reason you
have to believe it's false? Let's hear
it. Hudge
>> because there's two different things
going on here. There's the qualifier
like according to the contract, but then
she's making a claim. The influencers
are not allowed to disclose their
relation.
>> Yes,
>> correct. So, so what? Let's just let's
just hear that one more time. So, it's
untrue because
>> are not allowed to disclose their
relationship with Chorus or the 1630
funds, but that's not true.
>> Are you the accuracy of that? Why Why is
it Why do you think it's untrue?
>> Because there's two different things
going on here. There's the qualifier
like according to the contract, but then
she's making a claim. The influencers
are not allowed to disclose their
relation.
>> So guys, there's a qualifier like
according to the contract and then she's
making a claim. The influencers who are
not are not allowed to disclose their
relationship with Chorus on the 1630
fund. So that means it's untrue. Now I
I'll elaborate on Hutch's argument a bit
more here because he hasn't quite. So
according to the copies of the contract
view by Wired the creator signed the
influencers are not allowed to disclose
their relationship with chorus or the
1630 fund but some of them did is
basically his argument but some of them
did. So that's untrue but the fact that
some of them disclosed it is not
actually dispositive of the idea that
according to the contract they are not
allowed to. Someone could have breached
contract. Someone could have gained
explicit permission to disclose and that
would not change or they could have a
different contract. But that could not
change that would not change this claim.
That would not disprove this claim which
is according to the copies of the
contract viewed by a wide that creators
signed. The influencers are not allowed
to disclose their relationship with
chorus or the 1630 fund. Now if the
claim was the influencers are not
allowed, ignore this, ignore this first
part. If the claim here was the
influencers are not allowed to disclose
their sorry none of the influencers are
allowed to disclose their relationship
with the 1630 fund or chorus um and none
of them have if that was the claim that
might be untrue that would be disproven
by what Hutch is saying but that's not
the claim here. And in fact, the thing
that Hutch is identifying here, the use
of this qualifier for this claim
according to the copies of the contract
for this claim, this actually
strengthens Taylor's point. The thing
that Hutch said, this is actually a
limiting qualifier that makes it so they
are only making the claim that they can
substantiate. They are not making a
claim past what they have according to
the copies of the contract viewed by
Wired. So we're not saying this
absolutely even is the case. We're just
saying according to these copies of this
contract that we reviewed, this is the
claim. This is a limiting qualifier that
makes it a more solid like um they
absolutely can prove what they're
claiming. He's so dumb. He is full-blown
[__] illiterate. Cannot read at a
high school level. Does not understand
how clauses work in a sentence. It's
[__] crazy. Is the use of double
hyphen [__] up here? Is that what it
is?
>> Yes. Under the contract.
>> Under the contract. That's all under
>> No, but I I think the qualifiers is
>> very clearly. No. No. That's very
clearly what he's talking about is
what's allowed
>> according to the contract, but then
she's fun. But that's not true.
>> Are you the accuracy of that? Why? Why
is it why do you think it's untrue?
>> Because there's two different things
going on here. There's the qualifier
like according to the contract, but then
she's making a claim. The influencers
are not allowed to disclose their
relation.
>> Yes. Under the contract.
>> Under the contract. That's all under I
think the qualifiers
>> very clearly. No. No. That's very
clearly what it's talking about is
what's allowed under the contract. Do
you have any base to believe that's
that's untrue?
>> Why? But why wouldn't you verify that
that was being enforced?
>> Wait. That's why they came to talk to
us. That's why we have the article. But
Taylor,
>> so they're probably in breach. Hutch.
Hutch. Hutch. The answer is they're
probably in breach. The answer is
they're probably in breach. I don't know
what is in their contract versus what
they enforce.
>> No, but the question Hutch Hutch, the
question stands. Do you have a basis,
Hutch? The question stands. Do you have
a basis to believe that that's untrue?
Yes or no?
>> The framing of this I find
>> Do you have a basis to believe the
statement is untrue?
>> I The framing is dishonest. Do you even
disagree with me?
>> Is the statement is the statement true
or not? No. I I think the other part of
the contract so so I so so yeah yeah I I
I do I do but it's also it's kind of
like in poor taste kind of like lame to
just have a pylon and I have a different
problem with the contractual language
having to do with funnel through and
that's been done to death and I I can't
even get my point on that but I just
want to ask you Hudge do you have a
basis to believe that that statement of
the article is true yes or no
>> no not as it's framed no
>> you think that you either have a basis
you either have a base to believe it's
false or or you don't no hang You're not
saying like you're doing the slippery
thing, Taylor. There's two different
things going on here, right? So like
were they allowed to disclose their
relationship with Chorus or the 1630
fund? The 1630 fund that is this like
the separate fiscal sponsor. I
understand that that's like a separate
like obvious
>> No, they were they were accepting checks
from the 1630 fund,
>> right? So that's that's where they were
the fiscal sponsor. So they did a lot of
like administrative.
>> You have a basis to believe that
language in the article is untrue.
>> No. So the that's that's one $5. Thank
you for $5. Huge appreciate. Thank you.
>> Pisco.
>> Yep. Yep. There's a goal, guys.
Reminder, there's a goal right now for
bonus Pisco content.
>> True question.
>> So, we we do know that that in the
contract that they were that they were
not allowed to disclose that they were
had like a relationship with 1630.
>> So, it's a is that so the answer is it's
a true statement in the article.
>> Thank you. I'll pause the $5. Thank you.
>> Sentence right here. Tell me if you
think
>> doing my PS.
>> Thank you. Let's just let's just make
sure we hear all this
>> that it's untrue or not.
>> Question. So we we do know that that in
the contract that they were that they
were not allowed to disclose that they
were had like a a relationship with 1630
or
>> so it's a is that so the answer is it's
a true statement in the article.
>> So you know so what did he just say? So
we we do know that that in the contract
>> we do know that in the contract
>> that they were that they were not
allowed to disclose that they were had
like a relationship with 1630 or so we
do know that in the contract we they
were not able to disclose that they had
a relationship with the 1630 or and
assumingly he's about to say chorus what
does it say again Hutch in case in case
he ever sees this according to copies of
the contract viewed by Wyatt so the
contract says says the influencers are
not allowed to disclose their
relationship with Goris on the six.
Okay. Hopefully we're getting there.
Hopefully everyone's on the same page.
>> Is that so? The answer is it's a true
statement in the article.
>> Peacekeep this sentence right here. Tell
me if you think this is true. The
influencers are not allowed to disclose
their relationship with Chorus.
>> The paid rel Yeah, exactly.
>> No, not the paid relationship.
>> Yes. The relationship was the
relationship was
>> say that you said the relut
hutch you they're signing the contract
to get money. The point of signing the
the contract is that you get money.
They're only under the contract if their
relationship is paid. It's the whole
point. H the literally
>> what is he trying to convey?
>> Tell me if you think this is true. The
influencers are not allowed to disclose
their relationship with chorus.
>> The paid rel. Yeah, exactly. No, not the
paid relationship.
>> Yes, their relationship was the
relationship was
>> say that you it literally says the
relation did you or functionally that
they were paid at all. Did you read Can
you read that sentence again?
>> I can read it right now. According to
copies of the contract viewed by Wyatt.
>> Yeah, it literally even specifies here
or functionally that they're being paid
at all
>> that creators signed the influencers are
not allowed to disclose their
relationship with Chorus or the 1630
fund or functionally that they're being
paid at all. There's like three
different
>> the object there is relationship.
>> Exactly. Exactly.
>> The first one is chorus, right? So like
you're saying that they weren't not
allowed to disclose the relationship
with course.
>> The relationship is the object with is
the or the interrupt object or it's
describing what's the thing is that
can't be disclosed.
>> Pisco legit just slipping into like
[__] high school English right there.
Just legit just it's [__] crazy, man.
It's crazy having to watch a grown man
have this explained to him when he's
come in so hot. He's come in so hot
trying to just like pin Taylor ends on
this and be just sitting there
explaining [__] that most people learn
when they're like 13.
>> The rel the relationship with with
chorus or the 1630 fund. That's what it
says.
>> Yeah. Those relationships there
>> with is that a reasonable reading of it?
But we know and and I'm curious if if
when you were doing your reporting,
Taylor, like were you aware that
creators had been open that they were a
part of course before you wrote the
article?
>> Um you you can see that we actually link
to Ken Bener's New York Times article I
believe uh or reference it in in the
piece. I I literally talked about that
multiple time. It's me chorus the the
chorus itself like the sort of broader
entity that Brian Tyler Cohen started
was the subject of a New York Times
article that was very public. So
obviously I know that chorus was public
because I've also written about chorus
before. So
>> well then then I don't know how to make
sense of the sentence. The influencers
are not allowed to disclose their
relationship with chorus or the
>> Yeah. their relationship with chorus.
Exactly. They couldn't disclose their
relationship with chorus or the 1630
fund or functionally that they were.
>> They did though. They had many had
discussed their relation.
>> That's not what the but the article
describing the contract allows.
>> Guys, guys, let me step in here. We got
10 minutes left and I got to say two
things and guys been incredibly quiet
and I think we can pivot this last thing
into something that guy will really
>> sorry just like totally bails him out
here. So yeah, that that's all pretty
bad. That's all pretty bad. Now it's
kind of done there really. It's kind of
done there. There's that final
embarrassing illiterate moment from from
Hutch and that's that's about it. Um,
now we do have one final clip. It's kind
of funny.
>> Pis, was it true that uh the picture
that I and I and I took that I sent to
you, you described us as your Jews?
I certainly did not. I certainly did
not. No. No. But I I did see someone uh
I I I've seen a nickname for you, Soy
Pill. Can I say it? Do I get the Jewish?
I don't know. Can you is it
>> do I get the G word pass
>> the G word?
>> The [__] pill. I've heard that
>> boy isn't a so you can say it. I think.
>> All right. Well, I I don't know. Listen,
I'm not I'm not read into everything.
All right, bro.
>> You're scaring me with these questions.
>> I do want to I I I do want to get at
some point.
>> It's awesome.
>> It's awesome. So, yeah, that's that's
the last bit of that. Okay, that's the
last bit of that.